[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the hand of glory
a magical artifact associated with the
dark arts
that shows up a couple of times
throughout the harry potter series
but before we get to its role within the
world of harry potter
let's take a look at the myth and
folklore behind this dark piece of magic
yes that's right although perhaps not
the most well-known magical item
the hand of glory is not exclusive to
the harry potter series
in fact its history and folklore and
literature
dates back hundreds of years
establishing a reputation for itself
in an extensive collection of literary
work long before jk rowling chose
to incorporate it in the wizarding world
of harry potter
so when exactly did the hand of glory
begin to appear in literature
the answer to that is well a bit
complicated
you see we know that it first made its
appearance in various pieces of folklore
across europe but the issue is that by
definition
focal is defined as traditional beliefs
customs and stories
of the community passed through the
generations by word of mouth
so it would be quite impossible to put
an exact date
on when the myths and legends of the
hand of glory first appeared
what we do know however is that the term
hand of glory
derives from the french phrase me
declare
which directly translated means you
guessed it
and of glory man de glowach is said to
be a corruption of
mandragora or mandrake a plant that has
roots which look eerily like a shriveled
hand
we also know that real-life criminals
and those suspected of witchcraft in the
16th and 17th centuries
were accused of creating hands of glory
to perform
criminal acts which actually brings us
to an important point
there isn't just one hand of glory so
referring to it as
the hand of glory isn't technically
correct you see
since hands of glory could theoretically
be created there could be anywhere from
one to several thousand in existence at
any given time
now you may be asking yourself well then
how exactly
are hands of glory made well the exact
magical recipe
or spell differs slightly from source to
source
one of the earliest accounts in writing
can be found in petite albert
an 18th century french grimoire
otherwise known as a textbook of magic
as i mentioned there are various
different accounts of how to create a
hand of glory
but most sources agree that the hand
must be severed from a criminal
who has been hung at the gallows for his
or her crimes
some sources say that the severed hand
should be the left one
while others suggest that you must cut
off the hand and committed the crime
in order to successfully create a hand
of glory
for example this would come into play if
the criminal had killed someone
and they had committed the murder with
their right or left hand but moving on
once severed the hand must then be tried
and pickled
after it's preserved or mummified if you
prefer
it's used as a magical source of light
the illumination is created
one of two ways either from a candle
created by the fats of the dead criminal
whom the hand belongs to in which case
you would use the withered hand as a
candlestick holder
or by using each finger as an individual
taper
okay so now let's get to the good stuff
what magical powers does this dark
artifact possess
exactly that's right it's not just an
elaborate flashlight
in fact providing light is just the
beginning according to legend a hand of
glory was said to be able to open
locked doors render anyone its path
motionless or
unconscious and provide light to only
those who wield it
even in total darkness making it the
perfect dark arts object
for a thief if using a hand of glory
where the fingers provided the light
an unlit taper would also tell you if
someone in your path was awake
quite handy if you ask me it's also
interesting to note that hands of glory
like many other legends from long ago
were believed to be real objects at one
point in time
in fact the whitby museum in northern
england has a hand of glory on display
to this day
throughout literature the hand of glory
has continued to pop up
in modern storytelling from comic books
like hellboy
to popular television shows like buffy
the vampire slayer and supernatural
the hand of glory continues to be a
favored magical trope referenced by
authors and screenplay writers alike
which brings us at last to harry potter
in this series we come across the hand
of glory for the first time
in the chamber of secrets at borgin and
berks an antique shop in nocturne alley
that has a bit of dodgy reputation
for selling dark wizarding artifacts and
dealing with questionable witches and
wizards
after harry accidentally travels to
borgen and berks in nocturne alley
instead of diagon alley by way of flu
powder he witnesses
draco malfoy spot the hand of glory for
the first time
ah the hand of glory said mr borgen
abandoning mr malfoy's list and
scurrying over to draco
insert a candle and it gives light only
to the holder
best friend of thieves and plunderers
your son has fine taste sir
draco being a spoiled boy of 12 the time
excitedly asks his father to purchase it
for him but lucius malfoy
a pureblood wizard of great hubris
quickly dismisses the idea
of his son needing an item so often
associated with petty thieves
and so it isn't until harry potter and
the half-blood prince
that we see the return of the hand of
glory in all it's
well glory near the end of the sixth
book
we witness malfoy in possession of one
as he
uses it to see through instant darkness
powder
a magical powder imported from peru that
is resistant to most magic that would
normally provide light
such as lumos the charm that illuminates
the tip of the caster's wand
he was on his own clutching that awful
shoveled arm
his hand of glory said ron gives light
only to the holder
remember anyway ginny went on he must
have been checking whether the coast was
clear
to let the death eaters out because the
moment he saw us he threw something into
the air
and it all went pitch black peruvian
instant darkness powder
said ron bitterly we tried everything
lumos
incendio sedjini nothing would penetrate
the darkness
obviously malfoy could see because of
that hand thing
in many ways i think we are meant to
believe that the hand of glory malfoy
uses here
is the same one we saw him first express
interest in in the chamber of secrets
although it's never confirmed the fact
that malfoy uses a pair of
vanishing cabinets one in hogwarts
linked to one in morgan and berks
to get death eaters into hogwarts in
sixth book suggested he has likely also
procured the hand
from that same shop there's got to be
something said about customer loyalty
right the question of when he came into
possession of the hand of glory
is a bit more difficult to pin down
though it could have been
soon after he first saw it maybe lucius
decided the boy
could use a dark art artifact to better
help draco follow
in his own sinister footsteps or perhaps
draco had to wait until he came into
position of war power
being chosen by the dark lord to murder
the almighty albus dumbledore for
example
there seems to be a bit of confusion
around this from a narrative perspective
as well
you see before we witness draco with the
hand of glory ron makes a comment
quite early on in the half blood prince
before we know that malfoy is in
possession
of the hand of glory maybe he's broken
his hand of glory
said ron vaguely as he attempted to
straighten his broomsticks bent tail
twigs
remember that shriveled up arm malfoy
had what do you guys think
when did malfoy come into possession of
the hand of glory
as he had it all along since it first
caught his eye before his second year at
hogwarts
or did he finally manage to get his
hands on it because he needed it to
carry out his assassination attempts on
dumbledore
and the half-blood prince i'd love to
hear your thoughts and theories
as always please share your comments
down below and
that's it for this video i hope you
enjoyed learning a bit more
about this dark arts artifact if you
enjoyed the content
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
then what's he doing in borgin and berks
browsing for furniture
you